we'd be fools again dropping the
surprise single starring in the Lion
King and slay ye hit a red carpet with
her little cub Beyonce and her seven
year old daughter Blue Ivy won the night
holding hands and coordinated black and
silver ensembles check out the matching
mother-daughter details alexander
mcqueen tuxedo jackets tulle skirts and
intricate braids and in classic beyonce
style the singer dropped a surprise Lion
King single called spirit during the
premiere
[Music]
and while Beyonce dazzled on the red
carpet she did not do any interviews in
fact Beyonce's media silence has become
kind of a thing her last big TV sit-down
was with Oprah in 2013 she talked to
Kevin after her Super Bowl triumph in
2016 so why avoid reporters now
well Beyonce talked about protecting her
privacy in her 2013 HBO documentary I
always battle with how much do I reveal
about myself how do I keep my humility
how do I keep my spirit she does talk
after all directly to her fans on
Instagram as of this morning her Lion
King premiere post had more than 3
million lights Emmy winner Donald Glover
knows all about the Beyonce love he
plays Simba in the movie out next Friday
this is my son's favorite movie I wasn't
gonna tell him I was in it I was like
hey do you want to see The Lion King
tomorrow yesterday and he said yeah
Beyonce's in it right I was like yeah
daddy's in it to toe like daddy's in it
Hakuna Matata
you're singing on a soundtrack with
Beyonce come on man I know what an honor
for her and Beyonce set the tone for the
night's red-carpet theme stars showing
off their cubs
her Destiny's Child sister Kelly Rowland
brought four year old son Titans Jamie
Foxx hit the carpet with nine-year-old
daughter on Elise and her friends and
Stefan Ayesha curry pose with their
little scene-stealers Brian and Riley
then there's the red carpet fashion the
dress code was quoted Savannah she and
Meghan Trainor flaunted a fierce
interpretation come on Savannah chic you
follow the dress the newlywed of six
months brought along hubby darryl samara
and they were definitely feeling the
love that solo was interrupted by
keegan-michael key who invited the
couple to the premiere Meghan Trainor
craftsperson
while Keegan's high-pitched voice
definitely came in handy he plays the
hyena Kumari secret to perfecting the
hyena laughs here's the thing it's it's
not it's not a laugh sound listen when I
get into a kitchen I go deep okay by the
way we're gonna be at the UK premiere
this weekend I cannot wait to see
America's Queen with the Dutch it's a
royal fashion shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]